[Music]
in the last video we saw the use and the
importance of circles in our daily life
let's understand a circle in detail in
this video so what exactly is a circle
or how is the circle formed a circle is
nothing but a collection of points but
can randomly place points form a circle
no right so can you tell me how the
points come together to form a circle
that's right a set of points on the same
plane which are at an equal distance
from a single point form a circle yes a
set of points on the same plane at an
equal distance from one single point
this single point is called the center
of the circle and this distance between
the center and all the points is called
the radius of the circle now let's see
something interesting mathematics has a
lot of branches such as geometry algebra
logic number theory etc but for now
let's focus on geometry and algebra
let's see how we can represent a circle
in geometry as well as algebra we all
know that this is the geometrical
representation of a circle but do you
know its algebraic representation so the
algebraic representation of any
geometrical figure is called an equation
to find the algebraic representation of
a circle we need to find its equation to
find the equation of a circle let's name
a few things let the center be O and
that it's coordinates be H comma K
similarly let P be any point on the
circle with X comma Y as its coordinates
also let's denote the radius by R so the
distance between points O and P is
nothing but the radius
but how do we find the distance between
the points Oh aunt P since we know the
coordinates of O and P we can find the
distance Oh P using the distance formula
so we get this squaring both the sides
we get this this is the general equation
of the circle now that we've seen the
general equation of a circle can you
tell me the equation of a circle whose
Center lies on the origin since the
center is the origin the values of H and
K becomes 0 substituting these values in
this equation we get this and solving it
further we get this this is the equation
of a circle with the origin as its
center so in this video we saw how to
represent a circle in the geometrical
form Center O with coordinates as H
comma K and radius R we also saw how to
represent it in the algebraic form in
the algebraic form we solve these two
equations we will solve some examples
based on it in the next video
[Music]